Or how evident that we are facing an election
where you Galicians and Galicians
really have alternative doubts,
or 1 D.O. government party,
o 1 D.O. government popular party led by wheel
or 1 government
for led by Venega with me as president.
And this is what is currently in shogo.
And I think these are also
the most open elections in the last 14 years,
where there are
1 possibility of real fear within your reach of no Saman
Make history,
launching 1 change of country
to give sent
and that in addition
eh galiza can make for the first time 1 president
as free as possible to defend
ostuous interests,
to put the interests ahead
2 Galician and Galician editions.
I am convinced
that there is 1 change
eh unstoppable in the Galician society.
We will certainly go all out,
in this national team we are going out to win